today the iconic serena williams
announced that she's going to retire so
she's just about done making money on
the court but she's still the highest
paid female athlete of all time and that
probably won't change anytime soon how
she won 23 grand slam single titles and
do you know what the prize money is for
winning a grand slam millions she won
her last grand slam in 2017 and walked
away with a 2.8 million dollar prize
total serena has made 94.6 million
dollars from playing tennis alone but
she's making absolute bank outside of
tennis early in her career she earned a
13 million deal from puma but after she
won her sixth grand slam nike came
knocking on her door and offered her a
40 million dollar deal with a three-year
extension that would boost her earnings
to 55 million she's averaging about 15
million a year from endorsements from
these companies but she's also bringing
loads of cash from her investments back
in 2009 she acquired a minority stake
with the miami dolphins in 2016 she
invested in the ufc in 2019 she invested
in andela which is a job placement
network for software developers but the
list doesn't even stop there these are
the other companies she's also investing
in whose portfolio do you want to see
next